at this point if you're serious about
economic issues you've probably
developed sort of a more nuanced sense
of debt and deficit and oftentimes we
hear from the right very general and
almost meaningless in how vague they are
statements or talking points like the
deficit is bad debt is bad we need to
cut in order to improve the economy cut
spending of course they will always say
when a Democrat raises the deficit that
this is what Democrats do and they will
often campaign on we lower the deficit
and we will start reducing the debt even
by creating a surplus which of course
never actually seems to end up happening
and there's four or five layers of
deception there first of all Republican
George W Bush was one of the biggest
deficit exploding presidents so first
and foremost is the question factually
do Democrats increase the deficit
whereas Republicans lower it and at
least by counterexample we know that
that's not always true Bill Clinton
actually ran a surplus george w bush
blew up the deficit of course that you
can say well clinton had the benefit of
the dot-com boom and george w bush had
the detriment of the Iraq war and 9/11
and so on and so forth but at least the
big picture of it is that it's not true
to say Democrats blow up the deficit and
Republicans reduce it but then secondly
and this is what we've been talking
about more and more on the program and
we've even done some interviews about it
but stephanie kelton and Pavlina
Chernova and others more importantly I
would say the entire paradigm that the
deficit is objectively bad has become a
political football and I would agree as
a sort of general principle that just
increasing the deficit and accruing more
debt is not a good thing in kind of a
vacuum right but going into debt for
economically stimulative programs or
reasons like food stamps which have a
very very high economic multiplier
health care for all as another example
which we don't we don't know about for
sure but has been speculated about in a
number of studies
that's much better or we could say much
less bad than going into debt to give
rich people tax cuts which will mostly
be just put in bank accounts but even
taken at its merits we also now are able
to evaluate the promises that have been
made by Donald Trump when it comes to
so-called fiscal conservatism and debt
and the deficit so for example in fiscal
year 2019 which starts in October the
White House says we will run a 1.1
trillion dollar deficit the number of
dollars of the deficit is sometimes
wrest less relevant than how big is the
deficit relative to the GDP because if
your country is growing in raw dollars
it might also be anticipated that the
deficit grows that doesn't necessarily
tell us whether it's getting bigger or
smaller as a portion of the economy we
are going to see a bigger than 5 percent
deficit as a portion of the GDP for
fiscal year 2019 under Trump okay 5
percent compared that to fiscal year
2016 for example the deficit was only
about 3 percent of GDP in fiscal year
2017
the deficit was about 3.5 percent of GDP
and it has gone up twice now under
Donald Trump Trump's first full year as
president we saw the deficit as a
percentage of GDP climbed to 4.2 percent
and then again in 2019 now it's looking
like it's going to be 5 percent of GDP
so there's a bunch of like underlying
claims here that we need to explore
first of all Donald Trump told us that
the tax cuts on the rich and on
corporations we're going to grow the
economy so much that there would be more
tax revenue brought in particularly
corporate tax cuts the corporate tax
revenues that is the opposite seems to
be true so far tax revenue to the
government from corporate taxes has been
and continues to fall so then you say ok
well fine
businesses are paying less in taxes but
they're using that tax cut that Donald
Trump gave them to pay people more to
give raises
and to hire people right well no that
that's wrong that's also not happening
as we've separately reported from other
data most of the tax cuts that
corporations have received are going to
hang out executive bonuses paying out
dividends to shareholders and buying
back their own Company stock which has
the effect of driving up the price which
of course disproportionately benefits
the shareholders who are overwhelmingly
wealthy as well as the executives so
what we get to in the end is that the
amount of the deficit in and of itself
isn't actually the problem it never
really was and maybe the right knows
this or maybe they're only hypocrites I
think that they're both a combination of
hypocrites and ignorant because we know
that they only care about the deficit
when a Democrat is president and all of
a sudden when you have george w bush
it's excuses for why the deficit went up
or just straight up lies saying the
deficit didn't go up but more
importantly to me the ways in which
Republicans like Trump raise the deficit
are bad for the economy like for example
tax cuts for the rich and tax cuts for
corporations and this to me is actually
the bigger point and the bigger
conversation I think we have to make
just deficit bad deficit good dead debt
bad debt good that's not actually the
most important conversation to have
right now because we have a more nuanced
understanding that debt can be good or
bad the deficit can be a tool used to
generate real economic growth with a
high economic multiplier or it can be a
way to let rich people sock away more
money in their bank accounts what we're
learning is that if we say hey you know
what tax cuts for less wealthy people or
healthcare for all or food stamps or
educational stimulus we can go into debt
to do those things but because of the
high economic multiplier we get more
back later on spending money now on
education might increase the deficit it
might not right but it might increase
the deficit but later because we know
more educated people commit less crime
and we know that they end up generating
more revenue
because they earn more money in the long
run because they're more educated it's
actually a net decrease on deficit that
is a much more useful way to go into
debt than just tax cuts for the rich and
then here's the last thing that I think
when it comes to Trump's claims it's
just not being accounted for when you
looked at and this is it starts to get a
little wonky but I think this is
important so let my best to explain it
clearly when we saw the analyses done of
the ten-year impact of Donald Trump's
tax reform and that's the way these are
done what's the impact over ten years
because different provisions take a
while to be put into effect and we don't
just say what will happen next year what
will happen over ten years
the calculations were based on an
economy that was going to continue doing
really well for those ten years and it's
true that the tax cuts for the rich are
cutting government revenue but if the
economy does grow some of that is going
to come back not enough to make up for
the tax cuts for the rich but at some
point there's going to be a downturn in
the economy right and as you know I
don't pretend to know exactly when it's
going to be there's a good chance in the
next ten years there's going to be a
downturn in the economy how significant
it is whether it effects the stock
market and housing and employment what
areas we don't yet know but if that
happens forget about a trillion dollar
deficit under Donald Trump you were
going to have the deficit increasing
elements of his tax plan and some of
that economic growth some of which is
real just not nearly as much as Trump
promises that's going to disappear and
there are reports talking about two or
even three trillion dollar deficits
maybe by then a Democrat will be in the
White House and Republicans can blame
them but it's really important to
understand three four or even five
layers on which the deception and the
bad policy and the the just poor
economics operate on don't fall for it
because this stuff really will rot your
mind that's when it comes to debt and
deficit and then next I want to talk
about the GDP related lies that are
being